[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to behind the screens a weekly
movies talk show where we deep dive into
a topic we love with a new guest each
week and this week we have my dear
friend I GM's executive editor of movies
Jim Bovada thank you for having me this
is so cool I'm so excited you're here as
my guinea pig first gasps that's right
no pressure on me no pressure no friends
everyone else will have to follow the
template I said that's no pressure at
all well today we're going to be talking
about Star Wars and you and I kind of
met in a Star Wars environment at d23 in
I would believe it was about a hundred
and twenty degrees in the room that
we're little really sitting in yep yeah
Robin sweaty elbows right but we bonded
over Star Wars and what better way to
bond than over Star Wars like you get
your Star Wars skirt
I was sure come on and we didn't even
talk about this but we won there were no
notes exchanged I just knew in my gut I
had to do this now we're going to dive
in today to the best worst and weirdest
Star Wars the last Jedi series and I
feel like the last Jedi probably has
more series of any other movie that I
can think of because I mean a force
awakens I don't think there was enough
info to come up with super strong
theories and then the prequels you know
what the end game is so what do you what
are you going to do but the last Jedi
have quite a few on the interwebs so
let's run down some of the biggest ones
okay I'll do this one of the main ones
is through our Rey's parents and the
first year going to talk about is Ray is
Obi Wan's a granddaughter I first saw
this one on reddit and the gist of it is
that obi-wan calls out ray during her
force back vision she shares Obi Wan's
accent and she behaves like obi-wan
including using a Jedi mind trick on a
stormtrooper and then the theory also
says that it can't be Luke because when
maz kanata's in the palace castle and
says whoever you're waiting for is not
coming back but somebody else could she
says Luke which means Luke is not her
parentage right what do you think of a
obi-wan I think look of all the theories
about her pair
I feel like that one might be strongest
however obi-wan was pretty much a hermit
his old life at least according to the
Canon of the movies real nerdy now you
know when did he have time for lovin you
know it was just him in that cave unless
you know some something else and then I
love to like well she has a British
accent
because all people with British accents
even in Star Wars are all related course
they are I know which means that every
Imperial officer then is kin to obi-wan
Kenobi right I agree with you that it's
one of the stronger theory it's probably
my favorite of her parentage if she has
to be related to somebody they're
currently in the Star Wars universe
but yeah the accent and like the fact
that she's kind of mimicked his behavior
she judgments in him though I will say
that there isn't quite made those bad
decisions that he did it's not strong
enough but I also haven't seen anything
to discredit it yeah but I will say what
I had always thought was going to happen
tell me why think of this is there going
to reveal that raise Obi Wan's
granddaughter and then they're going to
drop the spin-off obi-wan movie that
fills in and then that makes Paul that
all went down either that makes perfect
sense actually that could be wider
they've been kind of dancing around
those rumors for a while look I think it
kind of it'd be a great way to tie it in
to the the existing saga without it
being over till like they're all related
everyone as the other ones did I think
this one would be interesting because it
would it would show that look it's not
all about the Skywalker's or other
obviously force connected for sensitive
characters out there and obi-wan Kenobi
is it would be kind of a nice redemptive
thing to considering that you know he
did play a part and sort of lying to
Luke about his parents and that you know
I think it would be a nice kind of thing
to generationally it pays off where
they're going as a narrative would like
the subsequent generation kind of
picking up the torch or in this case I
guess the lightsaber of the previous
generation so yeah I think it's cool the
obi-wan Theory does seem to be the one
that if it happened and would it make me
like a groan or something about like how
they went there with it
and I think you're you're probably going
to get to this I think you know the Luke
stuff and I know I don't personally want
that I don't either let's talk about
that Rey is Luke Skywalker's daughter
probably the most popular parentage
theory that people are starting to turn
on because the theory is that Ray's life
on Jack who is a direct echo of Luke's
life on Tatooine Luke's lightsaber
previously Anakin's calls out calls to
her and that Lucas so much stress that
this is the continuation of the
skywalker saga yeah but it is in terms
of kylo ren is a skywalker anyway is in
there and Luke is in there and it's Nate
you know it's the Skywalker saga it's
not the Luke Skywalker saga and you know
and Han was basically part of the
Skywalker family in the end so I think
the the I just don't see Luke Skywalker
abandoning his child because he knows
what that's like I don't I don't see
that happening I think I really do think
the the obi-wan stuff makes more sense
because you know even the lightsaber
stuff obi-wan gave the lightsaber to
Luke yeah you know and it so he kind of
is that connective tissue that just
makes more sense and isn't as sort of
like so no pun intended forced in terms
of yeah and there's a being like uh you
know we have to make everything in Star
Wars about them it doesn't have to be oh
yeah I think my biggest gripe with that
one too is is what you were saying if
Luke is her dad he's a horrible dad yeah
because why would he put her on Jack who
and honey was like no affair later yeah
I mean or anyone looking after her yeah
I mean why wouldn't he put her with Leia
who is like the head of the resistance I
think you know it it would also suggest
too that you know maybe if she and and
Ben solo kylo Ren spoiler came from like
the the basically the same background
but they were so young they don't quite
remember each other
separating them - given the sort of the
effect that obi-wan had on Anakin and
that's sort of I don't know just that
this is a stretch here but this whole
thing is a starch
no that could explain why they had to be
separated or something like that the
whole you know one could turn one to the
dark side kind of thing right I don't
know if I buy that ray doesn't remember
like that she was being trained and then
doesn't remember it yeah how does she
not remember I mean she wasn't that
young she unless she had a mind why fix
or something I don't know how long I
don't hold kids are purchased I don't
know what people can't make it I'm like
what is it like the newborn they're like
this is a seven year old
that's my college go what's wrong did
they talk yet yeah I said they're like
she I think maybe there could be
something like there was some Jedi trick
used on her to kind of wipe her memory
or something but you know they're I
think the one thing that really does
lend a little bit of credence to the
Luke stuff is that you know you see her
even though she's growing up basically
in the wreckage of all the original Star
Wars in the and she's get like the uh
the rebel pilot helmet and like the
little x-wing pilot doll right all that
that is kind of associate Luke with that
you know so I mean that's the one thing
where it makes you gives you pause but
it could also just be a misdirect yeah
what if it turns out she's not related
to anybody well let me uh algún say do
you think she's related to anyone I
think I mean does it ultimately really
matter that if she's not I mean it would
be kind of nice if she had no connection
to anyone that it shows that you know
any one of these people could rise up
and be the hero that you need if you are
if the force is strong with you and you
believe in it and all that's romantic it
would be a nice message but then again
you know they're there the Star Wars
loves themselves the Joseph Campbell
chosen one stuff and you know in you
know that maybe her being related is
probably going to end up being
I let me put it this way they might not
be as clever as we think maybe maybe it
is going to be exactly what we think of
somebody's kid that's that but it might
be better if she's not yeah I think they
probably want a connector to somebody
but who is the question I love your
obi-wan Kenobi there
holding back on that you lay the
groundwork here with last Jedi and then
we get you went back and we find out
what happened I mean I think look we're
in a shared universe kind of world now
and that makes sense that you would go
and have this spin off then I'm telling
you you heard it here for the hair rest
you heard it were your offers moving on
to a kylo Ren theory I used to think
this one but I thought tell you I don't
kylo Ren is a double agent and the
theory is that kylo Ren is secretly good
and has been pretending to turn to the
dark side to get close to Snoke and that
Han Solo actually ignited the lightsaber
that killed him and not kylo Ren because
when they're having that conversation
he's saying here's what I need to do
yeah and he's like I'll do anything for
you and then he does it himself instead
of kylo Ren doing it hmm no that's what
I feel like I feel like it's a now I
think that's being more clever than I
think the story it's really about is
that narrative Lee and thematically it
kind of Rob's kylo of stuff to deal with
in Episode eight in last Jedi if it was
just sort of in undercover admission
that went awry like it doesn't it
doesn't play the same way so no I think
it's going to be he was legit just this
angry kid get pulled to the dark side
and now has to figure out okay you've
gone as dark as you can now what do you
say that way to game yourself candy
redeem yourself seems pretty
irredeemable but you know I initially
kind of bought the series somebody said
to me I didn't even read it my friends
let it said it's me one time and I was
like that is very convincing but then it
unless Luke is Kandra percent in on this
it makes no sense like why would Luke be
a hermit and be like it's time for the
Jedi to end one of my peoples turned on
me yes I ran is just like in Hans dead
yeah yeah and I'm at one and I killed
her friends and yeah it doesn't make any
sense if unless Kyle they were like
we've got this crazy plan like you're
going to destroy the Jedi Order and then
and then yeah no I think it would be I
just think it's it's more
it's more of a complicated narrative
than Star Wars is known to to weave
they're they're kind of simpler tales
because they're very archetypal and
mythic and you know myths and legends
they're not that complicated to keep it
simple because you know these are
ostensibly meant for children and for
younger folks nerds like us just keep
them going into our into our later years
but no I think I think it's a it's a
clever theory but you know it's a little
too fancy for me no series there are
several and basically the theories are
all that Snoke is somebody that we have
already met a series have included Darth
Plagueis Palpatine maze window even Jar
Jar Binks there's probably more do you
think that Snoke is someone were jar why
yes I mean it would I get there kind of
justified Jar Jar happening though no
but do you think that Snoke as somebody
that we have already met it's possible I
mean you know I didn't think that until
I saw it was a photo that leaked of snow
in last Jedi recently it was a very
clear photo any as these very blue eyes
and it did kind of remind me a little
bit of of Palpatine I think it in his
head injury and sort of almost like he
has burns I'm curious what sort of event
would have happened like gee getting
that and then falling down a shaft of
course then the damn thing blew up so
good luck getting out of that he would
have had a crawling her ass to a ship
all that but I don't know am I not
supposed to swear in this Lex and I know
Clara but I think you know that's
possible I don't think it's mace windu
alright wild charge yard nope nope
Georgia jar jar's retired town folks
we're not dealing with him Plagueis I
want to say that they've already maybe
have said that that's not the case
yeah but Palpatine I mean it's possible
I think my favorite fan theory I've
heard is one you did mention
- he's a storm trooper banged his head
oh no I think that one now that that's a
guy look you got injured on the job
they didn't he got a really bad
settlement and I'm gonna work my way
back up I'm going to be in charge and
you're all going to pay for it now yeah
he got like fired after that yeah he's
like our man up and like yeah he was on
like workman's comp and imperial
workman's comp and then they get you
know the Empire seemed to end and it's
like what am I going to do now
I'll see you know what I'll start my own
empire and then there'll be that'll be
the next standalone movie is just the
backstory of yep how that's always what
happens after you take off your I'm see
the damage that was robbed like I just I
just actually remembered this that that
Pablo Hidalgo said that I get some the
novelization of the force awakens that
Snoke is humanoid but not a human so
that rules out about this about being I
mean look what is a human in the Star
Wars universe humans are essentially
right look at the Whitaker's and what it
would rule out mace windu and yeah yeah
alpha pain hello by the end Palpatine
was he really still human he was so kind
of yeah I guess I guess I can make that
argument yeah I don't know I mean it
might be that he is just uh maybe he's
from a species that we've encountered
but you know maybe he himself is not
been introduced maybe maybe he took his
like his being somehow his spirit if you
will and put it into somebody yeah so
maybe maybe the essence of him is
somebody we've known before but the body
might not be but if you're gonna do that
really gonna pick that old thing right I
think I he was really handsome once upon
a time he just you know just didn't
happen
aren't they all yes I was a looker back
in the very back of the day I was smokin
hot you could hide you say smoking huh
yep yeah did you I did I did I'm known
for my puns people for smoking good um I
think yeah I think of all of us I think
I like the Plagueis one the most because
I know he has a whole Legends thing that
is like what is canon what is not no no
that could be something that couldn't be
buttoned up from the movie standpoint
he's briefly mentioned in the prequels
and that's it yeah so I feel like
there's a hole do you think there's
anyone from rebels that it could turn
out that they're kind of forcing it in
silo oh I've heard this whole like Ezra
is Snoke theory possible I guess but you
know I mean I think at this point any of
these fanfic there is could be could be
do not be for stitches I don't think
they'll do that look I don't think that
they would make that big of a tie-in to
the to the television shows okay the
final one mm-hmm not even a theory just
more things that people are debating
okay will Luke died in the last day you
know what I'm I got ace I don't know if
this would be controversial but it's
possible that he was made to die and
then with the passing of Carrie Fisher
and the retooling of episode 9 what if
they have to rework it so that Luke
doesn't die because you'll need some
sort of legacy character and a sage
character of some kind for that third
film you know I mean look mentors died
in Star Wars movies Han died qui-gon
died obi-wan died Yoda died
Luke probably isn't long for this this
world but I do wonder if if I just don't
know if fans could take it if episode 9
we're definitely not having Princess
Leia and they kill off Luke and yet and
harness God again whenever you know
apparently we're not seeing Lando
anytime soon so like and I don't know if
you really want to go that grim but then
again it's the second movie they always
end on a downer note you know I'm
curious if if they aren't going to have
to somehow alter the story of episode 9
not just because of Leia but because of
Luke if if that was what was meant to be
you could tell how Booth died but maybe
you have to hold it to episode 9 maybe
not all at once for everybody I don't
think I even thought about it until you
just brought it up the fact that if does
Diane episode 8 we literally have no yep
well not c3pr we are - yeah that's true
even even Peter Mayhew is retired now we
got a different act yeah she Baca Jonas
wanted Sodom oh yeah no it's alright
yeah he said oh yeah the the main three
legacy characters would be gone and we
never got to see them all together that
is which is no working accessor and
all-star that is the worst yeah I mean
as they said the actors themselves were
like what a missed opportunity to have a
room no I know you could see that Hamill
was legit like kind of upset by that and
I guess I get on a narrative level why
but I liked Mark Hamill's pitch of life
what if I'm just getting there and I'm
just that little bit too late or
something like that it's just that one
moment of seeing them all together yeah
what do you think about the I know he
said it was a figurative thing but the
ghost of Han sort of hang over the whole
movie Rian Johnson said that and you
gotta be is like cover story recently I
thought that was you know that's
interesting like you know how does Luke
handle the whole Han thing especially
Frank you know he took off after kylo
Ren and now kylo Ren is killed Han and
Leia's widowed and she's dealing with
the resistance and in the first order
and all that and I think he's got you
know frog nuns hanging out on an island
I don't like this I like my Lords yeah
poor dissolving have you seen all the
the porgy stuff of people making cookies
into poor yes and also I went on repeats
I went on colliders that I can't go last
week yes and I Ken naps off mentioned
that he would like to cook aboard and
now people have been tour reading me
about cooking boards non-stop cool it's
real great well you know who toilet
cookie Borg and he walk
they put humans on the spent we saw that
come on and they were playing like
stormtrooper helmet protect their
adorable they look like my dog but they
will straight up eat you I'm going to
open up or calm like conservation
probably we're in a sec PETA on them
yeah yeah he and Peter stands for pork
for stance report that's right um what
were we talking about we were talking
about rope does he die oh we've done
yeah acted what does what does a poor
taste Augusta fine I'm not like to think
they're like sweet and sour no they're
not how dare you go great with fried
rice it's a lot you know I think what's
going to be interesting though here's
what I was going to say before we got
the pork is that it's going to be weird
to see Ray interact with Luke and Luke
be the one that doesn't want to be there
and her being like I wish Han was here
on what if I come out with me exactly
the total opposite of what they were
well that's kind of cool though because
it's also it gives him an arc again some
kind of a place he had to come back
around I like the idea right Callie look
you started as the new hope and I was a
man without hope without any sort of
faith he was he was the one that was you
know all about the force and and
bright-eyed bushy-tailed farm boy it
says the day and now he's just a
curmudgeon he's basically Clint Eastwood
in Gran Torino
yeah but with a lightsaber lightsaber
you know maybe not as racist but we
don't know how he treats everybody on
that island
you know man oh yeah well hey thanks so
much for coming in I brought everything
that they showed I took it to all the
places that the next guest won't go to
you know what all out in the first show
you were an excellent first guest of the
show thank you for having we're here you
guys let us know if you think any of our
predictions series are bogus if you have
that smoking gun they totally discredit
everything we say or what your favorite
theory is and Jim let everybody know
where they can see you oh I'm like
ign.com slash movies and also on Twitter
at Jim's a vida and Ashley I just want
to say thank you so much for having me
break a leg on your show oh my god
you're the best friend she can sorta go
hi guys